داخل الجثة المتفحمة
لمكتب رئيس بلدية ألماتي ، تجري الآن عملية تنظيف واسعة النطاق
يدويًا وبدأت الأعمال الآلية
لإصلاح الأضرار التي سببتها
الاحتجاجات العنيفة التي اجتاحت كازاخستان.
جلبت السلطات العشرات
إن لم يكن المئات من العمال
لتنظيف تداعيات ما كانت عليه تلك
المعارك في الشوارع هنا في أكبر مدينة في كازاخستان ،
الماتي ، ومن
اللافت للنظر حقًا أن نرى الحجم الكامل
للدمار هنا في مكتب رئيس البلدية
كما تقول السلطات هنا
دخل المشاغبون إلى هذا المبنى وأضرموا النار في
جميع
أنحاءه ، ويقول المسؤولون في كازاخستان إنهم كانوا على
وشك فقدان السيطرة ليس
فقط هنا في الماتي ولكن في أماكن أخرى في
جميع أنحاء البلاد
، قال رئيس كازاخستان إن الاحتجاجات
التي كانت في الأصل ضد ارتفاع
أسعار الوقود قد اختطفتها ما يسميه
اقتباس  قام بإطلاق النار لقتل إرهابيين واستدعى
قوة عسكرية دولية  بقيادة روسيا ،
قمنا بمنع التهديدات الخطيرة
لأمن بلدنا كجزء من
مهمة مكافحة الإرهاب التي
نحاول تحديد الأشخاص الذين ارتكبوا تلك
الجرائم ، وتقول الحكومة إن الأمور الآن
تحت السيطرة إلى حد كبير وهناك
دليل على ذلك في جميع أنحاء المدينة.
بالعودة إلى طبيعتها
، بدأت القوة العسكرية التي تقودها روسيا
انسحابها على الرغم من أن هذه
العملية من المقرر أن تستغرق تسعة أيام أخرى ،
لكن السلطات تقول إن حملتها القمعية
ستستمر حيث تم اعتقال حوالي 10000 شخص
وقتل أكثر من 160
ناشط معارض جان بالوت ماما كان
في  يقول الاحتجاج إن الأمور بدأت
بسلام ، لكنه أيضًا تعرض للضرب على يد من
وصفهم بالمحرضين
الذين قدم لنا هذا الفيديو الذي يبدو
أنه يظهر ما حدث وهذه
الصور لما بدا عليه بعد الهجوم
يقول ماما إنه يعتقد أن أعمال الشغب كانت
ذريعة ل  قمع عنيف
قررت الحكومة
ذبح شعبها
وأعتقد أنها مشكلة أخرى أكبر
لم يتم ذلك
بمساعدة
قوات الأمن الكازاخستانية فحسب ، بل
بتدخل القوات الروسية
، تنفي قيادة كازاخستان مهاجمة
المتظاهرين السلميين وتقول إنها فتحت
تحقيقًا كاملاً في
من يقف وراء أعمال العنف التي اندلعت في
غضون ذلك ، تعهد رئيس البلاد
بتحسين أوضاع الشعب.
الظروف المعيشية وإعادة بناء المواقع المتضررة
بأسرع وقت ممكن